the first church official bong we got
some para solji we got a bag of [ __ ]
stars and guess what [ __ ] damn
no looking back [ __ ] Zeppelin [ __ ]
presents the devil showing up
[Music]
oh yeah what do you think of that
[Music]
safe smelling somebody's [ __ ] out of
a shot which smells a little better not
really
you ready to leave the seasons done we
thought you got bronchitis last time
what's happened you bad [ __ ]
Monday June 27 the day the devil was
buried at sea sup [ __ ] sup [ __ ] there
you go suck that [ __ ]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
I'm trying to tell you you guys want to
dangle with these [ __ ] fruitcakes
they tell you this and that is [ __ ]
when you're running with [ __ ] uncle
Joey in the crew there ain't no looking
back [ __ ] as I've been telling you
that these [ __ ] people been lying to
you with their [ __ ] pineapple Express
they've been lying to you for how long
can you sit there hey High Times they're
[ __ ] amateurs
[Music]
that's a little one that blows out of my
[ __ ] that's right to a bomb I'm
saying we don't [ __ ] around no more if
you don't like it
but what's calling a brine or one of
your buddy yeah but here on the church
we go beat up in 24 you understand me
just like that blue you ready for round
two
what are you [ __ ] nuts Oh what sure
this cuz this is it this is how we do it
no more lies stop lying to yourself
these [ __ ] people telling you they do
this and that they do nothing but you
guys bought that [ __ ] you [ __ ] Momo
see this is how we [ __ ] do it here
[Music]
you see that huh
get it together whether it's whether
it's Jared Cosby and don't matter who
the [ __ ] it is you bought into it these
people are [ __ ] lying to you
we're running [ __ ] here [ __ ]
bodies [ __ ]
[Music]
that's it now you're looking at me Joey
so what you could do magic tricks what
so what
the Stardust compels you
Oh baby baby bets have you been a man
like me oh yeah oh baby baby been two
hundred apiece [ __ ] we're opening up
one eight right off the back you know
why cuz it's Monday you gotta take a
chance with your life you gotta do
something you're sitting in Ojai and
[ __ ] the roller and what the [ __ ] for
what at the end for what to be cool you
[ __ ] plans you got a picture of a
parrot on yarn nobody gives a [ __ ] when
you're in a casket you know what they
give a [ __ ] about the truth [ __ ] and
that's what I'm bringing you 7:24 I
don't give a [ __ ] I got one foot in the
grave one of an an appeal what do I give
a [ __ ] so what we say raise another
bonnet you ready for your stars your
stars are calling you look at me that's
okay this will bring you back four stars
will bring you back let's count one two
three
[Music]
and you know what people I'm doing a hat
that's 900 well look at that might even
eat the tail [ __ ] you know why Jesus
died for your sins I'm going to [ __ ]
see the devil out of respect to you
people cuz I love you that's it
this ain't no [ __ ] this ain't no
[ __ ] okey doke I'm not moving I don't
give a [ __ ] i crack jokes we [ __ ]
laugh a little bit and we move on right
or wrong I tell Lee before you come here
check your pH take your vitamin C always
when you deal with uncle Joey your
vitamin C always got to be at Uncle up
the part if not ass Owen Benjamin he had
one vitamin C and look what happened
vitamin C creeps on the THC it keeps it
in check I'm saying God drink a little
orange just take a tablet or something
[Music]
when key number one you got to always
keep the fluids in there because if not
you got nothing what is it time for a
bong hit yes it is
Oh baby baby
[Music]
I'll clean this out just give me a
minute here I don't want you to think I
down on my [ __ ] soldiers of death how
do you think you become a soldier dead
my [ __ ] sitting your house and
playing games or burning [ __ ] you don't
become a soldier a debt by open you
become a soldier death by kidnapping
over driver and delivering his ship the
rest of the night and then giving them a
half a yard and let them know you're
loving it I'm saying anyway
[Music]
Oh Oh baby baby what you bad
[ __ ] listen I want to give a
little shout-out to my brother who came
first of all I want to give a shout-out
to the whole city of Philadelphia you
[ __ ] are bad to the bone you
understand me you sat there you listen
to my abuse and you applauded it's like
going to the circus you know that
[ __ ] zebras gonna die anyway I love
you people Philadelphia with all my
heart I'm coming back I'm gonna surprise
you [ __ ] beside that my man man
Timmy Holloway showed up hey since 1982
you picked me up around the corner you
know I love you I think
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah it's [ __ ] Monday [ __ ]
if you ain't jumping down and you're
alive oh [ __ ] you're alive there's
people who are [ __ ] dead Prince can't
play the drums no more he's dead you're
alive
[ __ ] make it happen join the [ __ ]
party here we know better than you I'm a
[ __ ] degenerate always will Oh what
the [ __ ] people you know it's a
beautiful day to be alive the Sun was
out your kids are healthy your wife's
healthy your mom's alive your mom your
dad's alive and you're sitting there
bitching what the [ __ ] it's all these
fun last night I felt like [ __ ]
crying when I went inside because least
he's got a [ __ ] thing
are you [ __ ] kidding me you don't
mean people walking around like I hate
my dad meanwhile he's got a relationship
but is that in this issue this issue and
every [ __ ] family unless you know you
grew up in a family don't talk to each
other there's issues but you put them
aside man I give me a lot of [ __ ]
credit you don't say that's why
he's doing another bum head out of this
back [ __ ] yeah
so your dad's alive your mother's life
not about Father's Day Mother's Day
that's please white Gentiles if you will
if your parents alive guys it's gotta be
Mother's Day and Father's them for that
every [ __ ] day man
I know my parents are alive it would be
like that every day I call them every
day with good news or tell them to go
[ __ ] themselves what's the difference in
just money
BAM that's uncle Joey's free if I had
[ __ ] okay you [ __ ] when I'm laying
there in that [ __ ] caste but one of
you people gonna go [ __ ] Joey today
but no gives a [ __ ]
it's about our love for each other while
we're smoking the bonds the bonds not
gonna do it it's like when you do
jujitsu yeah you're flying through the
air with your breathing
it's time others do it the jujitsu I
never knew that it's just about to
breathe everything else is [ __ ] magic
you don't say like when you get your
first [ __ ] it's magic even if a
[ __ ] blows it's magic because I'll see
you guys ten minutes you two get your
[ __ ] together I love you stay back uncle
Joey
and your boy Lisa yeah we love you
daughter